laurent cesari bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france les
troupes américaines ont donc quitté un
officiellement l'afghanistan joe biden
lui doit s'adresser aux américains
aujourd'hui beaucoup s'interrogent aux
états unis à quoi ont servi ces vingt
ans de guerre qu'est ce que retiendra
l'histoire finalement selon vous l'échec
américain
l'échec eux il est réel ce ce qui sera
retenu va dépendre je pense de la suite
dé la donne de la politique américaine
soir ce sera et c'est peut-être ce que
soit à éden un une modération des dates
de l'interventionnisme militaire à tout
va je me dis je ne dis pas qu'elle
n'aura pas encore bien durera peut-être
des choix du terrain plus comment dire
on choisira peut-être des terrains moins
moins difficile pour des interventions
que l'afghanistan soit et
nico maudire ce seront les appels des
républicains actuellement qui seront au
kek qui seront entendues et qui qui
ouvriront la porte à de nouvelles
interventions au nom d'une e d'une lutte
contre le terrorisme gaudreault comeau
qui n'ont de l'objet peu près si
justement mais ce que ça c'est un coup
dur sur la scène internationale pour les
états unis on se souvient notamment de
ses mojos hayden qui souhaitait
redevenir le gendarme du monde
je vous est-ce que c'est un coup dur je
ne pense pas la puissance américaine en
tant que telle n'est pas entamé la
question de la crédibilité
qu'on met souvent en avant il n'y a pas
forcément une perte de crédibilité parce
qu'en fait tout cet accord et ce retrait
en fait balader un peu plus un peu
rapide que prévu c'est certain il ya
environ deux semaines comment dire d'
avance sur le calendrier si j'ose dire
mais il était quand même prévu depuis
2020 est ce que des choses que je vois
c'est que la bei den voulait absolument
réorienter la politique américaine vers
la halle à l'affrontement s'était trop
dire mais le la la rivalité avec la
chine là effectivement si elle pas de la
part des talibans qui prennent des
engagements mais de la part de l'état
islamique que khorassan s'il ya une
poursuite de deux dates entre attente à
l entendre hors d'afghanistan à diverses
et organisations qui peuvent y trouver
un refuge
ça peut effectivement
distraire des moyens de renseignement en
particulier américains vers la région et
là effectivement aller contre le
programme général de bail de alors la
communauté internationale en tout cas va
devoir faire désormais avec les talibans
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu a adopté
une résolution pour que les afghans
puissent quitter le pays en toute
sécurité sans pour autant exiger de
jaune de zones protégées sur place à
kaboul c'est ce que souhaitait notamment
emmanuel macron qu'est ce qu'on peut
retenir de cette posture de l'onu je
crois que si la zone protégée je ne sais
pas et j'ai pas de de résultats en dire
plus précis sus de leurs informations
plus précises sur le détail du vote je
sais que si la zone de sécurité protégé
a été refusé c'est par exemple position
britannique parce qu'elle aurait demandé
que l'onu envoie des deux des soldats
sur place sata semblait impossible à
faire sans l'envoi de 100 l'envoi de
casques bleus et vu le contexte ça a été
refusé maintenant évidemment ballet
ganis temps est un état souverain qui a
un nouveau gouvernement et laisse la
plupart des ambassades ont été retirés
et donc maintenant évidemment on va
avoir la situation habituelle avec les
états où il ya un changement radical de
gouvernement une révolution le cheval
comme ça alors conservant toujours cette
résolution de l'onu la chine et la
russie se sont abstenues mais n'ont pas
voté contre moscou d'ailleurs se disait
plutôt favorable qu'est ce qu'on peut en
déduire
eh bien on peut en déduire que les états
unis pendant que la la russie comme la
chine sont dans l'expectative
dans la nuit la chine a chez un
diffuser un appel disant qu'il fallait
que la communauté internationale
guide l'afghanistan le terme est
absolument
significatif puisque d'un côté il ya une
volonté me d'engagements on leur tourne
pas le dos mais en même temps j'étais
un côté un peu paternaliste
ce qui montre bien qu'ils seront jugés
au sac et je crois qu est effectivement
maintenant il ya
manifestement les autres états à tant de
l'afghanistan ces actes alors selon le
porte parole des taliban et s'est
exprimé il ya peu de temps la défaite
américaine est une grande leçon pour
d'autres envahisseurs c'est un message
clair pour le reste du monde
qui voudraient envahir l'afghanistan
habituellement je pense que j'ai dites
le moi parce que moi je ne bois pas
évident à la comment comment est-ce
qu'on peut interpréter justement puisque
s'il n'y a pas de
deux pays qui veulent aujourd'hui envers
la gaine nice temps comment est ce qu'on
peut comprendre cette déclaration du
porte parole taliban cette mise en garde
oui mise en garde alors là oui je pense
qu'elle s'adresse non pas comment dire
voilà président président by dane qui
lui a bien fait comprendre qu'il voulait
repartir et le faisant ils ont la
parfaite continuité d'autres hubs mais
peut-être aux éléments au parti
républicain qui de manière assez
opportuniste actuellement utilisent
cette
famille utilise le retrait pour demander
à un nouvel engagement et ça ça monte à
si vous avez des des gens comme patron
des républicains mais également même des
gens comme panetta l'ancien ministre de
de la guerre je préside à la défense
pardon de démo démocrate qui dit qui
disent il faut il faut il faut y
retourner je pense que c'est à eux c'est
à eux que s'adresse cette mise en garde
merci beaucoup laurent cesari pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes professeur d'histoire
en histoire contemporaine à l'université
l'ars